pour moi ces gammes bars peuvent
également
écoutez sérieux
art il dit quoi est atteint quand tu
sors les daevas ben tu te regarde dans
la glace
[Musique]
ligue 1 point dis moi dis on était nous
sape être à part tes oreilles
il ya eu but qui changerait quoi
qu'est-ce que j'ai repeint je changerais
rien charge est que plus moquer libre et
du genre
rechargeable miku est un tueur santé du
petit quand tu étais un nouveau né tu
voulais ressembler je connais une phase
de picabia qui dit moi monsieur je me
déguise en homme pour n'être rien tes
baisers là c'est sûr insidieuse à
strasbourg dans les parent
tu t'es vu mourir comme john lennon
imagine des couilles
c'était pas de l'intrépidité c'était du
courageux parce que quatre habitants sur
le fait et on change la question
le courage c'est de vaincre sa peur
où elle est mon petit garçon regarde
bourg tu penses que tu vas mourir quand
le creux pour bientôt un choix pas de
mathématiques quand je vais crever
thür a un coût
j'espère s'envoyant en l'air deux morts
mais sans louper sens en envoyant la
purée quand ce qu'il faut class classe
et tu te souviens 47 48 et jour que de
la placer chez delhi avec le sel ont
tapissé d'astral
j'avais les clés
il était la caisse mais je crois c'est
pour ça j'ai tout est noir
que c'était mon marché il avait des
chiens
[ __ ] ma vie pendant qu'elle joue
on aurait dit je passe le haut du rhin
faire et j'ai tremblé fait sur un lit
terriens carré de trois mètres sur trois
que je fais idem juin et partir y avait
démis rodez et picasso l'éden
ça va marier révélateur de soufre et de
super duke et pourquoi tu as brûlé et ou
à l'âge de 30 ans des croûtes qui pour
brûler et avait le couteau à ne pas
attraper puis je change de temps à
passer du d'expressionnisme dadaïsme
surréalisme cubisme apprécié puisque
c'est une écoute par l'échangé au
créneau et sa grand sérieux maintenant
être piégé en 1959 du quart et ses 30
ans
je chante pour pouvoir un jour reprendre
la peinture explications tiennent pas
trop tard si j'ai encore tué j'arrête de
boire de temps usa par le bas j'ai
encore les cuites et visuelle il ya une
phrase de la croix qui est très cruel
mais qui est superbe
ils ceux ci un patron doit savoir
attraper au vol un ouvrier tombant d'un
échafaudage dans le temps que met en
plus dur mais j'ai peur
entre guise new york ghabbour et
gainsbarre touré préféré garder le pain
les larmes je suis bien terminer sur les
claviers
donc on peut pas continuer vers le haut
il a une muse et et ouais je suis bien
encadré réussi à aider bootable où les
étirer ses pièces sont tirés est-ce que
les donjons tour en q2 rien jour tu
crois pas qu'il serait temps pour toi de
rejoindre un beau en abyssinie 1 ne
serait pas
ouais pour moi c'est vraiment avec
picabéa parce que celui qui la polluent
jésus-christ rastaquouère alors aidez
vous il ya beaucoup plus ce qui l'attiré
claquette mais exemplaire allawi on est
servi par les cons d'ailleurs trop le
premier était un conte gainsbarre et je
t'emmerde
evgeny sokolov qui place un bon bouquin
ou que gallimard publié parce que cette
aide soit amélie mais je suis en trop
entre de [ __ ] pardonne fab éthique
entre jeunes et égide a fool veut en
faire je n'ai
mahias bourg tu as dit que je ne peux te
réponds pas trop con
l'homme ait créé les dieux linverse
reste à prouver
tu es toujours interrompu non je crois
que je viens au polythéisme c'est à dire
je mets toujours les duos coup de plus
rien de peur et recchi qui le panneau
mais dans mauvaises nouvelles des
étoiles
[Musique]
j'ai dit dieu y accueille c'est tout
simple jésus était de race timide il a
dit je suis fils de dieu et les montrer
1942 tuant vous français savoir que j'ai
une étoile de shérif jeunes ans le père
l'avait remarque je te les beaux mecs
qui faisait l'occupation j'en veux aux
miliciens os x et prescriptions baffes
en coup c'est vrai que parler hier
pendant une perquisition de cacher
quelques kilomètres dans l'adoption de
la carte d'état-major dixit
[Musique]
oui j'ai eu des sursis d'henry et ça
c'est un recul important
coucou
et posez une colle et comme petit peu
con qui mènera sûrement un ouvrier qui a
coulé le titanic iceberg en corrèze
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux